hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 9 review the
episode was titled 409 conflict it was
written by Kyle Bradstreet and directed
by series creator Sam s mail the
headline here is we finally got us a
Deus group meeting and Eliot and Darlene
were able to pull off their hack they
finally delivered a blow directly to the
top 1% of the 1% and it feels like a
victory there's a relief in that after a
season that I've thoroughly enjoyed but
has taken its time in making it to this
moment and what's more we have another
look inside Eliot's mind and there's a
lot to talk about they're white roses
reeling at the end of it all but hey we
still have four hours of mr. robot to go
before we reach the finish line the main
story of episode 9 is surprisingly
straightforward and relatively easy to
follow well what they're doing to pull
off the hack is beyond my technical
knowledge the simple explanation of what
they need to do is intercept two-factor
authentication codes to bypass the
bank's security and wipe out their
accounts to pull this off they need to
get all the members of the dais group
together in one place so they can hit
them all at the same time if they don't
hit them all at once there's a chance
that someone could warn the other
members and that wouldn't result in a
complete victory of course this doesn't
go off without any detours whiterose
changes the location for the day of
group meeting opting to have a
face-to-face with Phillip price the ex
CEO of ecore she realizes that there's
something going on between price and
Elliot so she meets with Phillip alone
trying to find out more about what
Elliot's up to and even though that gets
turned on its head the fact that she's
at this other location really
complicates the plans for the hack
Elliot and Darlene had secured a hotel
room across the street from the original
location because Elliot is still out of
commission mr. robots the one that shows
up they start to get ready but soon
realize that price and White Rose are
the only people who are at this location
this means they have to split up because
as mentioned they need to get everyone's
phone
in order for this thing to work so they
decide that Darlene should go she has
everything she needs to pull off the
hack before she does she learns about
Angela
and prices relationship that prices her
father when she gets to the new location
and she realizes there's no way she's
gonna get inside so she has to pull out
a new plan which involves making enough
society video she releases that that
gets everybody running around that gets
the people inside worried because they
start seeing alerts and after she packs
the device that opens the parking garage
exit trapping all their cars inside
she's able to get them out on the street
and get access to their phones while
this is all unfolding there's all these
great hallmarks of mr. robot as a series
that we see the great party shot where
we see the camera enter the front door
and go through the crowd we get a look
at a guy who is most definitely supposed
to be Donald Trump in attendance we see
that security is super tight around
these people we get little ideas about
how they operate the oligarch says I
just got off 11 hour flight on Christmas
Day whatever Minister Zhang is planning
better be good he mentions that his
wife's pissed off and his girlfriend
won't take his calls well all of what
Darlene does is impressive and I really
enjoyed the call back to the original
feeling of eff society with the video my
favorite part of this was the phone call
when mr. robot decides to call prices
phone and gets White Rose on the line in
that exchange White Rose brings up
Angela and that she's not really dead
and it was really well put together in
that everyone involved knows that White
Rose is probably full of [ __ ] but you
still can't help but wonder what he
wants to show Elliot we see price take
notice when he mentions Angela's name we
see the transition from mr. robot to
Elliot and then by far my favorite part
of the whole episode is when Elliot gets
the message to turn on the TV and he
says here's the thing I don't need help
right now
you do and that was just the best moment
of the
thing there were also a lot of really
funny moments in this michael
christopher did a fantastic job in his
final performance as philip price at one
point white rose says you think I can't
survive being doxxed and price just says
I have no idea I'm as curious as you
everything does work out for up society
here once elite gets white roses number
they're able to move all the money out
of the dais group accounts there's a
great exchange on the steps where price
ends up buying time reminding White Rose
that he would rather see her lose than
him win and we hear the phone's buzzing
and he says something wrong old sport
and what stands out the most to me is
that we see that white rose is
completely unraveled by the situation
like it was beyond her comprehension
that they could pull this off that it
was just not possible and yet it
happened in a complete meltdown white
rose grabs a gun off one of the
bodyguards shoots price dead in front of
a ton of witnesses the bodyguards grab
her up and get her out of there but it's
fairly obvious that there's no way that
they can get away clean here just to add
insult to injury she sees Elliot leaving
the scene on the way out then of course
later we see her in her apartment in her
mother's dress putting on makeup and we
hear people pounding on the front door
the police trying to get inside we hear
gunshots there's definitely a gun battle
that happens and it's crazy when you
think about it the most powerful person
in the world at least in this shows
universe is in a pretty difficult
position at the end of it all now we
could get really nitpicky here and
discuss how much this would really have
an effect I don't think it's worthwhile
I think the point is that the hack at
least set everybody back everyone in the
dais group their information is out
there when Darlene released the video
she also released documents that they
pulled off of the dark armies Network at
some point whenever they had control I
guess they've also been doing all the
research to this season about who was
members of the group and the Cyprus Bank
and all the connections so we have to
imagine that they've been outed as
who they are and what they've done
regardless of how long that will set
them back the main thing here is that
white rose lost her composure and killed
someone on a busy street with lots of
witnesses and there's really no going
back at that point for her also before
this whole thing went down we found out
that price passed a thumb drive with
information related to Washington
Township plant so we know that Eliot
will be going there in the next couple
episodes that's promising because that's
the one of the biggest mysteries of the
show that it still has to answer what
exactly is White Rose doing with
Washington Township what is she trying
to move to the Congo what has this all
been about and we did have the boardroom
that is Eliot's mind
Magda his mother mr. robot and a younger
version of himself I've watched this
scene several times and I wish I could
give you a very clear explanation for
what's happening I've read quite a bit
about the ID disassociative identity
disorder which is what Elliot has and
still I don't exactly have a great
explanation for how this is gonna play
out I favor the theory that there's a
host identity that we've never really
met or if we have it's never been
clearly defined I think it's super
interesting that mr. robot points out
that Darlene may be the key the poor boy
as Magda refers to this other identity
with other alter mr. robot says that he
woke up two months ago for Darlene
there's also mention of I'm going to
tell him what he's done and it's all
super exciting like I'm really feeling
good after this episode as far as the
ending is concerned it's like Elliot has
won the first round against white rose
but we can't expect that she isn't gonna
go down without a crazy fight that's
gonna involve what her idea for this
project is and it's gonna involve us
understanding the different alters that
are within Elliot and how things turn
out for him we've lost another main
character in Phillip price rip Phillip
you are not a good person I don't feel
bad that you didn't get to come out on
top at the end but you delivered some
quality
some moments and definitely help move
this series along in your existence I
think a lot of people were probably
hoping for a Tyrell return here I know
there was pre-season photos that people
keep putting up about him showing up at
this meeting that definitely didn't
happen Tyrell still feels dead to me
always good to see Elliott and Darlene
working together the opening shot was
the biggest like surprise seeing that
hallway that we see in the trailers to
the preseason realizing that that's
outside the boardroom inside Elliott's
head definitely makes me want to go back
and look at those first couple trailer
breakdowns I did and parse out which
scenes we still haven't seen we're
getting close to the end game now
everything that's left has to be coming
out in the next couple of episodes I
felt a little bit surprised in the way
that mr. robot carried himself inside
that boardroom with Magda and the
younger Elliott we've just seen all this
emotional stuff where we found out where
he came from and how that all happened
and this almost made it feel like that
he's still keeping things from Elliott
working behind his back I guess that all
depends on what it is they're trying to
do how they're trying to get him through
this situation and what their end game
is as far as revealing to him what they
think he needs to know I'm not getting
too worried about it at this point but
it did stand out to me it's like wait a
minute mr. robot was just completely on
Elliot's side a minute ago in the
previous episodes and now it kind of
feels like he's got an agenda behind the
scenes although his entire existence is
there to protect Elliott so I guess
that's what he's doing I guess I really
like the idea of the integration of them
working together and being honest so I'm
probably just reading too much into this
the fall of White Rose is certainly
something I hadn't anticipated obviously
I thought they were gonna have a
showdown and I hope that Elliott would
come out on top but I didn't realize
that there would be this external
pressure put on the situation by White
Rose losing her composure and murdering
price with four hours left to go in the
series so there is a lot to think about
and a lot to talk about what a show what
an episode what a series
I love these characters and I'm really
going to miss this after it's all
/ let me know in the comments what you
think about this is it a real victory is
there something that we're overlooking
is there any way the White Rose can
bounce back from what happened here
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
we'll talk to you soon